wonderful people you know crazy enough
to buy it for the kind of money it was
and they weren't crazy I mean now I know
the business they were smart they were
saying this guy doesn't know what he's
doing well we'll take this [__] and
you know double his sales in five
minutes Genius of you to only sell 80 of
it though well that was not genius see
everybody thinks I'm so smart I am not
so smart Stevo I was thinking oh yeah
they'll make it worldwide they'll double
it yeah the 20 for what I've got for the
80 and it didn't work that way it it was
uh what if you hung on to it though what
if you still had that 20 today
oh yeah that'd be a whole different
story see that would have been genius
but I had to sell it within seven years
see they're a public Trading Company and
you can't have Partners like that you
got to have uh you know so they made a
special deal with me but it's not like
they [__] me just said I wasn't smart
enough to know that
when they took it over they dumped a
bunch of money into it so the profit
margin when I owned it I had no and put
no money in I had four sales guys I
didn't know the [__] I was doing it was
just selling like crazy you know
couldn't keep it on the shelf so I was
making all this money every year I was
making like seven eight million dollars
profit in my pocket a year for the last
those last three years as it averaged
out to 6.7 million per year so that's
what they went for three years what was
my average net and I went [__] so they
offered me 10 times net which was 67
million dollars and I'm going [__] man
that's you know I was flipping out and
then I thought [__] I love this brand
I'm having a blast and making all this
money it's growing man [__] you I don't
want to sell it you know what would it
take blah blah blah that's how it got
jacked way up but the point is the 20
then also they start dumping money into
it they charge 13 management fee they
had all these things yeah and so the
profit margin went down so my 10 times
well they offered me I end up paying 15
times 15 times earnings on the years
after I sold it it wasn't earning nearly
as much money ah since they weren't
talking about 10 times what you had made
off of it that's right they were talking
about what they were making because they
had 37 sales guys and right and trucks
and [__] sure yeah it takes money to
make money yeah but they you know they
came out good in the end after they got
rid of me
now trust me I did not get [__] but I
[__] myself because a lot I actually
got 97 ml instead of a hundred ah darn
it
I'll tell you that three million I could
have given to you Stephen you killed
yourself with that money yeah you
wouldn't be here today yeah depending on
the year you
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now yeah
dude